- On this episode, the last
seven minutes dominate.
(hip hop music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions and I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is the ask,
you threw me off, India.
- [India] Sorry.
- No, this is the,
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're watching?
- [Staphon] This is episode,
you're watching episode--
- [India] No, and, oh my gosh.
- [Staphon] Hello everybody
this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 189 of
The #AskGaryVee Show,
and clearly we are in a very,
we are clearly in book mode right now.
This is the night before
the big day tomorrow.
It drops like it's,
I was gonna say like it's
hot but I didn't like that.
It drops tomorrow, I'm very, very proud.
The early reviews are in
and it's widely considered
one of the great literally example,
literaler, literer, what is it?
- [India] Literary?
- Literary examples of
business in modern time,
according to Tamara Vaynerchuk,
mother of Gary Vaynerchuk.
But more importantly, the vibes are good.
We're sitting here, I'm
gonna be on CNN tonight,
so a lot of you can
comment after that aired
and you can talk about that.
I've got Good Day New
York, local New York,
Fox tomorrow, I'm heading
to St. Louis tomorrow night
for a big event in St.
Louis, then Atlanta,
then Boston, then Austin, that rhymed.
I'm feeling really
good, India, but this is
189 ofThe #AskGaryVee Show.
- [India] That's true
- That's the #AskGaryVee book.
- [India] Mm-hmm.
- Do you love the book?
- Yeah, I really love it.
- Did you buy, like, 40 million copies?
- Yeah, I bought 40 million copies of it.
- Did your mom and dad buy the book?
- My mom bought a book.
She doesn't understand half
of it, but she bought it.
- Did she like it?
- Oh shit, she's gonna
watch this and be like,
"I understand!"
- Yeah, India.
Why are you making that voice?
It's unfair, don't--
- That's true, she's much cooler that.
- She's much cooler than you.
- She is cooler than me.
- Can we get your mom to sit here
and take your spot for an episode?
- She would love that.
- Done.
- She's gonna be in New York in April.
- Done, done.
- Oh, shit, I'm so excited.
That's awesome--
- Alright, India.
Here we go.
You know, it's funny, I don't
know if you've seen this
I've sort of, on the book tour started,
and I've had a couple people last night.
Did you see anybody do that last night?
Were you there?
- The show? Yeah
- Yeah what I've been doing with them
on selfies and stuff, the
show, it's cool right?
- The show, yeah it's like a thing.
- Let's do it official right now. 189.
Ready, Let's
- Get into
- The show!
Alright let's do it, I'm feeling good.
I feel like a couple of people mentioned
this is a new golden era.
I do feel it the last four or five,
have been really tight,
Staphon got a little head nod
that means it's been tight.
Buy your book, buy your book.
- [India] From Kyle,
how are you balancing--
- I feel like we should
do something special
for the book.
Like if you buy one,
if you tag somebody.
Oh I like this tagging idea.
Especially in a Facebook game,
I know some of you are watching on YouTube
but we're going to do something with.
Don't let me forget.
Actually, let me do it,
because I'll forget.
Tag somebody that you think is not aware
of all of this that should get the book.
And I'm going to pick five people,
because five is my lucky number
of people that were tagged
that responded to the comments.
So you tag somebody, they jump in
and be like, "What are
you talking about Ricky?"
I will pick five of those people
that actually respond to the tagging
and send them a signed
personal copy to them.
Now I know you're thinking,
"Now wait a minute, I love this show
"and I want a personal--"
Well sometimes you need to give.
- [India] Give to get.
- Give to get.
- [India] Kyle.
- Kyle.
- [Voiceover] Kyle Reed asks,
"How do you balance saying
"no to good things so you
can say yes to great things?"
- You know Kyle, you're talking about
decision making and time management
and opportunity costs is
a tremendous question.
Who gets to decide what is good or great?
Is first and foremost.
What may be good to me
may not be great to you.
For me if I can meet Ric Flair for dinner
that would be great, for India,
are you excited about having
dinner with Ric Flair?
- Yeah, totally.
- Do you know who Ric Flair is?
- No.
- Exactly. Now name one
of your favorite bands.
- I don't know. You know who
I really had dinner with?
Jeff Bridges.
- I don't know who that is, the actor?
- Yeah.
- I know who that is.
Give me a band that you love right now.
- A band that I love right now?
- Follow me here.
- This is really scary.
- Just say it, stop being scared.
Some random.
- Grimes. Grimes.
- Good, I don't know
anything about Grimes.
I never heard of Grimes.
And you'd be like,
Hey the lead singer of
Grimes, it's a singer?
E-mailed right now and said,
"I want to have dinner"
I'd be like, delete, like
I don't even know, right?
And so who gets to decide
what is good and great
and that's why I'm answering this question
with that little skit.
Which is you don't know until you do it.
And so, Kyle.
Kyle, too many people
crippled by this question.
And I'm going to get
serious now for a second.
You won't know if something
is good or great until
it actually happens.
Some of the greatest things that ever
happened to me in business
look terrible on paper.
Wasn't somebody fancy,
wasn't fancy, you know?
It just was kind of like, oh wait,
and then that person knew
and then I connected them.
Meeting Blaine Cook, the original CTO
of Twitter for a taco
at South by Southwest
on the dawn of South
by Southwest this week.
That didn't look like one of the greatest
meetings of my life, but it turned into
one of the greatest meetings of my life.
This happens all the time.
Too many people are crippled by
the right hire, by the right meeting.
I say work harder, work more efficient,
make more 15 and 30 minute meetings
that leave you more
time to do more things.
And create more opportunities
and don't be crippled by choosing the
right opportunities or not.
So the answer is, nobody
can answer that for you.
Normally you can't answer it upfront.
I did a bunch of podcasts that I
never heard of the people before.
And I think some of them
have been paying dividends.
And I did a podcast
with Shaq that is going
to air shortly.
On paper it looks like Shaq
is a greater thing than good.
But I think we're going
to sell more books,
from some of that good because
I didn't realize the
audience that person had.
Be more efficient with what you do
to allow you to do more things.
Then you don't have to worry about
the subjective and non controllable
like knowing what's good or great.
That's the recap.
- [Voiceover] Nathanial asks,
"Gary, you've said YouTube,
Facebook, Twitter, Periscope,
"and Instagram are the big players.
"What's your opinion on Vine?"
- I think Vine has taken a secondary spot.
I still think there's
a real community there.
I think Instagram and Snapchat
took a lot of those Vine celebrities.
There's still plenty of
stuff going on there,
I'm spending less time on there.
It's now in the niche and young category.
I look for mass and older category.
That's where I'm betting on those things
that I brought up.
So I think that Vine has a place.
As I'm talking right
now I'm going to look up
where Vine is in the
rating system right now
in the app store.
Which is always a great
indicator on where things are.
But to me, I would rather
pay attention to what's
going on MusicAlly right now.
By the way Snapchat is number one
in social networks, three games,
then Snapchat, then Facebook messenger,
then Facebook, then
Instagram, then YouTube,
the next thing that pops
up is Pinterest at 18.
Which is interesting. What's App at 21.
MusicAlly at 25, Twitter at 27.
Look at that, MusicAlly above Twitter.
And I keep pushing MusicAlly and
everyone is like, ehhh.
Kik, very under the radar,
very big with younger demo, that's 34.
As of this moment.
There's that Wish app that
I've been telling people about.
Periscope at 49, real player there, right.
Here we go, here we go,
here we go, here we go.
Tinder at 75.
No Vine yet by the way.
And Vine has been slipping.
and I feel like Vine's been,
Tumblr is at 108.
You know I've been down on that.
GroupMe at 122, LinkedIn at 140.
No Vine.
And so that's, that's kind
of how I feel about it.
Just looking, triple checking here,
maybe I missed it, because
that could be the case.
No Vine.
So let's go to categories real quick.
So I look at data, and I go by vibe
and right now in social networks,
Vine is--
Is it even categorizing in this?
I got to find it.
It can't be this low.
I don't even know where it is right now.
I don't know, anyway,
that's how I think of it, India.
That's the bottom line.
Cool.
Go ahead.
- [India] Video from Benjamin.
- Benjamin. Vine where are you.
I feel like I'm missing it somehow.
Go ahead, play it.
- Hey Gary, Benjamin Holmgreen here.
You said you wanted some more interesting
videos for the show so I
went by this busy street
in the big city and
wanted to ask a question.
The question is, how do you
feel about employee poaching?
Taking employees from
someone elses company
and bringing them to work for you,
good, bad, or indifferent? Thanks Gary.
- I think this is a very
easy question to answer.
I think people hire from other
people's companies all the time.
This isn't nursery school,
this is business.
And if you can steal somebody
from another competitor or another company
that you think brings
benefit to your company
and you've got recruiters.
I mean, we have, seven, nine,
10 full time recruiters here
at the VaynerMedia.
They're just pounding, hitting it,
and trying to find the
right people for us.
So I think in big
business, this is just part
of the equation.
Poaching? Poaching makes it seem bad.
You mean employee recruitment?
You guys, I'm sure you're getting e-mails
from recruiters, from
LinkedIn all the time.
And it happens all the time.
That's why I try to build a really,
I'm very proud of our turnover.
Voluntary turnover here is incredibly low,
and that means we're building culture,
people are going to
believe in me as a CEO,
believe in Vayner, and so you need
to focus on building a good business
so that people are unpoachable as you say.
But I think that's common practice,
I don't think there's anything.
If there are shady practices where
people are under contract, but normal
every day recruiters trying
to find people for jobs.
That's like asking, what do you think
about having an accounting department?
Or what do you think about having
an office for your business.
That's table stakes,
that's oxygen.
That's normal business behavior.
So I think you're eluding to something
that I guess lends itself,
I love how you how
you hacked the video.
I guess it's lending itself to like,
Hey you stole my developer
or you stole my CTO
well build a great product
so that nobody is stealable.
Build a great culture,
so nobody is stealable.
I don't own India.
This is voluntary.
Build something great that
people want to be a part of.
You want to be a part of this, India?
- Yeah.
Cassandra.
- Cassandra.
Why did I,
why did that happen?
Okay.
- [India] I read somewhere
that being nervous--
- Staphon, did you buy a book?
- [Staphon] I can buy a book.
- This is unbelievable.
Can you believe Staphon, you
didn't buy a book either.
Oh my God, I saw it directly in your face.
Guys can you please buy one copy tomorrow?
That would matter to me.
Tomorrow is a big day.
Tomorrow is a big day, where like
I do the three book giveaway
and the super eight.
We did free book give away,
which is going to be exciting,
everybody took advantage
of that on instagram.
Made the right decision
because that 55 dollars
is going to turn out to be gold.
But tomorrow is a big day for me,
tomorrow is a day, it's release day.
Above and beyond.
I'm asking, I'm going to
hit up everybody I know
I'm going to fly into
St. Louis and be like
just one, just one today,
can I count on you guys
for one copy?
Now here's the real big question.
Can I count on you for one
copy from a random friend?
Which means you'd be in for two.
- [India] Like buying it for them?
- Well I don't want to spend your money,
could you convince somebody to buy
a copy for themselves because
it will be good for them?
Alright. You felt very
confident, you felt shady.
- [Staphon] I have a couple
of friends that would like.
- You're going to say it like.
- [Staphon] They know who you are.
- Do you think they bought a book yet?
- [Staphon] No.
- Yeah, what the, please.
Cassandra.
- Cassandra.
- Let's remember that anytime we
have a Cassandra let's do that.
- Cassandra.
- [Voiceover] Casandra asks,
"I read somewhere that being
"nervous is a good thing,
do you agree or disagree?
"Do you ever get nervous?"
- Sure I get nervous.
I mean, everybody gets nervous.
I get nervous not that often.
Because I'm not putting myself
in nervous positions anymore.
I don't have to feel nervous about
hitting on a girl anymore.
I don't jump out of planes,
that would make me very nervous.
Trying to think of the
last time I was nervous.
Maybe a heights thing,
even that I've gotten better about.
Did I see like a snake that scared me?
I think I saw a snake somewhere,
a big snake.
I'll tell you what makes me nervous,
I don't know if it's nervous,
when I see Xander almost falling
and almost hitting his head on a rock.
Is that nervous, or am I scared,
what is that?
- I think that moment
that you see him fall
you get nervous.
- A consistent nervousness.
I don't get nervous
before I speak or do TV.
- You're not always
nervous about kid stuff.
- Right right.
Nervous is a trait,
people should get nervous.
I believe that you do not get nervous.
I get a weird nervous energy
before I speak or go on TV.
But I'm not nervous, I'm so jazzed up
that I feel like insane.
So it's like a cousin
of nervous, that moment.
I feel like, if you were
a competitor you're just
going to get that feeling.
Like I'm not really nervous when
we're shooting five on five.
I'm thinking,
I really want, I really hope that AJ
is on my team because I might get nervous
that I'm going to get into a fight today.
If we're on opposite teams.
I don't tend to get nervous,
and I think if you're,
this is a business show,
so if you're asking about,
I think being nervous in
a business environment
is a bad sign, I do.
I do think that it means
you're not prepared,
it means you don't have it yet.
That it factor.
I do think you have interesting energy.
Nervous energy.
But like flat out nervous
I think is a tell you
don't have A-list stuff.
That being said, some of you may
be nervous and crush it every time
I have a little bit of that.
I don't want to call it
nervous because it's not.
It's adrenaline.
But I don't think nervous is bad,
I don't think any emotion is bad.
I think it's human.
Fear.
Look do I think like, anger or cynicism
are there things I don't appreciate,
or things that I think are a
waste of good energy, sure.
But I don't think any of them are bad.
They're just natural.
We're all human.
We all got our stuff, you know?
That was it? That was the show.
- [India] Oh no, there's a question.
It's another video,
It's one of my favorites, I think.
- Wow, really. Wow look at this.
- Hey Gary, it's Eric and
Dave Rhoden from Arizona.
- Hey Gary
- Father and son.
We have a YouTube channel where
we teach people how to
make signs like this.
Got over 300 videos.
We post 6 videos a week.
The name may sound familiar because
I got ten signed books from
you on the super eight.
About 25 minutes in.
You pulled my name and almost
threw it back in the bin
but thank you for not. I appreciate that.
Thank you for all you do.
Our question to you is,
We're all over facebook,
we post to facebook
six times a week,
and I'm using facebook darkpost
so we're getting really
good reaction there.
But we want to grow our brand,
we want to grow our name,
grow our audience, what
platform do you think
is best to go to next?
Our demographic is
somewhere between 45 to 65
years old and woodworkers, obviously
people that are interested in woodworking.
So you can tell me, tell
us, the next platform
that we should go into.
That's really what we're looking for.
Appreciate your time, Gary.
Thanks for all the great
stuff, love you man.
We'll see you later.
- Bye Gary.
- Bye.
- Bye Gary, that was so awesome.
That was awesome.
What are their names again?
- [India] Dave and Eric.
- Look, I think when I was looking,
India saw me, I was looking
at your YouTube data.
Kind of making some assumptions
on your facebook data.
I think that everybody, this is great,
this is a great question
because I can answer
for so many of you.
Everybody is looking for the next thing
before they've really won the last thing.
I think there's a lot of
work to be done, guys.
On your, let me give you
a huge piece of advice.
I would make those signs.
You should, here's what
I'd like you to do.
I'm going to give some real
tangible advice right now.
- There's their channel.
- There's their channel, so
Dave what I'd like you to do
is I'd like you to make
these amazing signs
for 50 to 100 influencers on YouTube.
I want you to make these amazing signs for
50 to 100 of these other
YouTube influences.
Look at what you did here,
and you just got exposure
on a bigger YouTube channel
by asking this question.
You're hacking.
I would actually rather you cut down
from six episodes a week to three.
And take all that energy and time
and e-mail out, search here for whatever,
the genre you think your world is,
and reach out to all these other
hundreds of thousands of YouTube providers
that are producing great content
that might be in your demo.
And don't go from Michell Phan,
with a billion people,
go to people that have
100,000 subscribers,
200,000 subscribers, they
haven't made it big yet,
and reach out and say,
"Look I'd love to make a sign for your
"around your logo for your YouTube show."
They'd be pumped because
this looks incred--
I mean these guys are
clearly good at what they do.
And so what you need
to do is more collabo.
The real thing that people
are missing is collabo.
Like, there's a lot,
if I was on DJ Khaled's
Snapchat right now,
I'd be like, big shout
out to my boy Gary Vee.
That's another channel, I would grow
100,000, 200,000 followers in a heartbeat.
Ads are great and you
should definitely do them
but collabo, collaborations
for all of you at home are
very very very important.
And I think you are actually making stuff,
so you can bring something,
a real hand craft work.
A bunch of people are going to
forget you guys, I don't care cowboy.
But one out of every 50
people that you e-mail
is going to say "That's
cool, I want that."
Then they're going to give you a shoutout
to their 200,000 person, again,
cowboy show, sign show, or just kids,
it could be anything.
And that is going to
get you much better ROI.
I would cut down the
shows from six to three,
this is actually tremendous advice
for so many people.
Cut down on the content creation
and start working on distribution.
Distribution my friends,
collabo and distro.
That didn't work.
But collaborations and distribution.
You need more awareness.
What you did by getting on the show,
by grabbing India's heart
was an absolute victory for you.
Because there are
absolutely 50, 500 people
who are watching right now that are going
to subscribe to your channel.
Follow you, buy a sign,
or whatever your KPI is.
You need more distribution and awareness
not more content, not the next platform.
Facebook and Youtube is
exactly right for you guys.
You just need to change your behavior
to respect collaborations.
Which are a gateway drug to distribution.
You need more awareness within
that ecosystem, that's
what you need to be doing.
Some good advice there on the show.
Feels really good, that's a very good way.
Staphon, we're going to try
to sneak in a show tomorrow?
- [Staphon] Yes.
- In the morning?
- [Staphon] 10.
- 10 AM? Guys tomorrow,
hopefully I'll be able
to put out a show, I'm a little worried
that it's going to be the big day
and things might get tight and crammed
and this and that, so if I
don't get a show in tomorrow,
190, which I think is.
Remember I wanted 200 to be the show
that was going to be the day of the book.
- [India] Yeah.
- And that makes sense, because
we definitely slowed
down, and the DailyVee stuff
and all of this, but
you know what,
I'll just going to do it right now,
because I don't want to take the chance.
I want to take a moment, in closing
to thank you guys all so much.
I guess 18 months ago or so,
maybe almost two years ago.
We started this journey around
the #AskGaryVee concept.
And here we are on the dawn
of the book coming out,
so much momentum and so much love.
And I just thank all of you so much,
tomorrow is a very big day for me.
And I've so enjoyed everything that
I have been providing to
you guys as a community
and very honestly, and you
may know this about me,
some of you really know this about me.
I'm weirdly very excited
to get into May 1st
where I'm kind of out
of this right hook zone.
I really want to take
second to thank all of you
for allowing me, giving me the permission
to throw my right hook,
to have your support,
to ask you for eight books.
Of the same book?
Yes, of the same book.
You know I really appreciate this moment
that you've given me to kind of
at least ask for the cash in
against all the up front value.
I'm really looking forward to
getting it on the back end.
The other thing is, Staphon I
want you to put it up here.
Everybody, and this is
probably my biggest ask.
Sure, I would tell you
to have one a and one b
for tomorrow, one a
would be one more copy.
Because I want the momentum,
and like spiking to number one
on Amazon would be amazing, and it comes
from volume not from quantity.
So anybody you know who needs this book,
tomorrow is a day of like, you've already
committed so many books, tomorrow is a day
to say to one person,
like I did with you two,
just one person, if all of you get
one person to buy just one book.
It changes a lot for me.
But the one b is, and
put it up here, Staphon
link it please on Facebook and YouTube
and don't forget, I'll get really pissed.
Is the Garyvaynerchuck.com/bookreview.
Everybody who has an instagram,
I have a page on my .com showing
how I want an instagram review.
Which is not a shout out,
like I got it, it's awesome.
No, when you read it,
to leave a long review
on Instagram with a photo.
That would really mean a lot to mean.
Doesn't cost you anything above and beyond
it would mean a lot to me.
I'm really curious about.
I think it's the right execution,
I think the attention sits on Instagram.
So that's my one a and one b.
Thank you so much for your attention
which is the asset.
Thank you so much to everybody
who came out last night.
In New York City, 600 strong
at 92nd street Y.
Stephanie Rule, you crushed it.
I enjoyed staying for two hours
doing all those selfies and book signings.
I'm looking forward to doing that in
Atlanta, St. Louis, Boston
and Austin this week alone.
Many more in the future.
And so big ups, Dublin and London
and Sydney, got a lot of stuff coming up.
Really excited to meet so many of you,
thank you so much for the love.
This is an exciting journey.
And tomorrow starts the next chapter
of that journey, so thank you.
Question of the day.
Question of the day is you know what,
I was going to say, are you're
going to do one a and one b
but that's too self serving.
Let's go a different direction.
Question of the day,
what's your kind of story.
Actually I need something to read
on that 24 hours each way to Sydney.
What's your story?
What's your #AskGaryVee story.
What's your story,
what's your kind of story
on this journey together,
it may be a microstory
from episode 109.
The collective, maybe
you want to write it,
one day I stumbled.
Maybe it's, I've been
getting a lot of emails
from people getting results.
What's your story from this whole
#AskGaryVee experiment?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)